نبدا معك حسان مسعود اوضاع الجبهات طبعا
والمعارك المستمره لكن في البدايه ما
اهميه تلك المناطق والبلدات الاربعه التي
تقول القوات الاوكرانيه انها استعادتها من
الروس وحلفائهم
نعم حسن هذه اهم التطورات عند الجبهه
تحديدا الجبهه الواقعه جنوب شرقي اوكرانيا
جنوب مقاطعه
على حدود مقاطعه زابولوجيا اعلنت القوات
الاوكرانيه انها استعادت السيطره على اربع
بلدات هذه البلدات هي بلدات صغيره اذا
اردنا ان نذكر اسم هذه البلدات هي البلدات
بلاغو داتني
مكاريفكا واستروجوف تقع في مربع واحد
مساحته حوالي 50 كم باتجاه الجنوب جنوب
مقاطعه دنيتك وباتجاهي ايضا الجنوب الشرقي
لمقاطعه هو كل هذا كل هذه البلدات هي
بلدات متلاصقه قريبه من بعضها البعض على
نهر يسمى موكريالي القوات الروسيه
الاوكرانيه على ما يبدو انها استخدمت هذا
النهر وعبرت على ضفافه باتجاه عدد من
البلدات من اخر النقاط التي ت عليها
القوات الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه
تحديدا في المنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه
واتجهت نحو هذه البلدات وبدات باستعاده
البلدات بلده تلوى الاخرى لا يمكن ان نقول
ان لهذه البلدات بعد استراتيجي كبير او
انها بلدات او مناطق حساسه او مهمه لكن
الاقتراب بلده تلوى الاخرى والتوجه نحو
عمق هذه المناطق ربما يؤدي بالقوات
الاوكرانيه في حال استمرت بهذا الاتجاه
ورغم ان لذلك
يحتاج وقت طويل ومساحات طويله الى انه على
ما يبدو ان القوات الاوكرانيه ارادت ان
تتجه باتجاه البحر الاسود ومناطق ومدن
اساسيه في البحر الاسود من بينها ماريوبل
على سبيل المثال وهي في عمق الجنوب ولكن
هذا يحتاج الى وقت ربما على الاقل والى
مساحات كثيره
القوات الاوكرانيه لتقطعها بهذا الاتجاه
ولكن التطور ايضا ان القوات الروسيه كما
تقول القوات الاوكرانيه فجرت سدا على هذا
النهر التي تتقدم عبره القوات
الاوكرانيه وهو نهر كما ذكرنا مكريالي
وهذا الامر ادى الى فيضان المياه على ضفاف
هذا النهر ولكن القوات الاوكرانيه على
لسان المتحدث باسم جبهه تافريا هذه الجبهه
التي تشهد تطورات اكدت ان هذا التفجير لن
يؤثر على تطور وتقدم العمليات هذا الحديث
الرسمي عن اربع بلدات فقط هو بالتزامن مع
حديث غير رسمي
تشرحه الخرائط وايضا المواقع التي تتابع
هذه التطورات عند الجبهه عن حدوث ايضا بعض
الخروقات عند جبهه زابولوجيا من الجهه
الغربيه لهذه الجبهه الجنوبيه الغربيه
وهذا ما نتابعه خلال الايام القادمه
لمعرفه المزيد من التفاصيل
روسي رسمي او عسكري لما جرى في دنيا
ازدهار الروايه الروسيه تختلف تماما
ومعطياتها مختلفه بشكل كامل تتحدث عن
استمرار للقتال واستعاره للقتال هذا الخط
الذي يبدا من مقاطعه
على اختلاف شبهاتها والتي يستعير فيها
القتال منذ نحو اسبوع من اليوم وصولا الى
مقاطعه
الروسيه تتحدث عن استعاره للقتال وعن صد
هجمات متتاليه للقوات الاوكرانيه شمال
مقاطعه
بالتحديد تقول وزاره الدفاع ان كل هذه
الهجمات التي تشنها القوات الاوكرانيه يتم
صدها بشكل كامل اذا ما عدنا الى مدينه
دانياتك حيث نتواجد ثلاث جبهات اساسيه
يجري القتال فيها وتتحدث الدفاع الروسيه
وايضا المقاطع المصوره التي تنشرها من كل
هذه الجبهات اكان افدي افكارج شمالا او
حتى ما التي استعاره فيها القتال قبل
اسبوع وقرات فيه القوات الروسيه والسلطات
الروسيه بدءا للهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
كلها القتال فيها مستعد تتحدث وزاره
الدفاع عن صدها هجمات وايضا عن تكبيد
القوات الاوكرانيه خسائر في العتاد
والارواح ما يمكن فهمه من ما تنشره اكان
الدفاع او حتى المواقع العسكريه الروسيه
ان هناك قتالا محتدما كما اشرنا ولكن ان
خط الدفاع وخط بالاحرى القتال بين القوات
الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه ثابت لغايه
الان يشن الطرفان محاولات للخروقات في
الجهه الاخرى ولكن اي منهما لغايه الان
وفق الروايه الروسيه لم يستطع التقدم
باتجاه مناطق السيطره اكانا القوات
الاوكرانيه او القوات الروسيه يوم امس
وصبيحه هذا اليوم جرى كثيرا الحديث عن هذه
المنطقه التي تشكل تقاطعا بين
ومقاطعه سافا هي فيرميسكي هناك قتال مستعر
تحدثت عنه المواقع العسكريه بشكل كبير
ويبدو ان السيطره على تلك المنطقه هي ما
زالت في تحت سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه ولكن
يبدو ان القوات الروسيه تشن هجمات مكثفه
باتجاه تلك المنطقه لمحاوله خرق الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه واستكمال القتال ليس فقط في
دنيا ايضا في مقاطعه
الواقع اجزاء منها تحت سيطره القوات
الاوكرانيه
مراسل الجزيره حسان مسعود شكرا جزيلا لكما